i wanna we gotta hit on one more team
here and i wanna ask you some things
about the titans but let's talk about
vic beasley's prior team which was the
atlanta falcons
i know you made a trip there you know
peter
saints bucks that's all we talk about in
the nfc
south i mean matt ryan julio jones we're
the super bowl not too long ago
we know what they're capable of what was
kind of the mood
in falcons camp right now down there in
atlanta
well you know they're again trying
they're
just like you know they're a little bit
like tennessee in that they're trying to
manufacture a pass rush now
and you know and so right now i think
that's an issue
and i think you know playing great
early in the secondary is really
important
remember a couple of years ago when they
had this secondary that looked like
it was going to be one of the nfl's best
uh
units for a long time and now all their
all their corners are gone
you know all their corners are gone and
they've basically reinvented
a cornerback group and so i think it's
going to be
really really important you know aj
tyrell
the kid from clemson is going to have a
chance to play early and often
when one quarter of your schedule is
against tom brady and drew brees
you know the secondary you cannot
underestimate the importance of that
secondary i think that's one thing
the other thing is you know i i don't
know how you guys feel mike i saw you
talk to him a couple of weeks ago but
i just looked up i was looking at the
roster in practice and i said holy crap
matt ryan's 35 years old right
you know he looks like he's 26 first of
all
uh he looks exactly the same way he's
done it i think all these guys
kind of are going to the tom brady
fountain of youth school
because now ryan wants to play for a
long time
he's got great weaponry my question
about atlanta
as you guys can tell is i don't doubt
that there are going to be a top
five six seven offense in football
i mean they need to be a top half of the
board defense for them to make the
playoffs
yeah agreed with that peter you're right
they got to stay healthy on that side of
the ball they got to deal with some
really good offenses
their pass rush hasn't been as good what
you mentioned right off the bat the last
few years
and yeah they got a guy in who isaiah
oliver who's a draft pick out of
colorado at one corner who's going into
year three
and now you're probably gonna have aj
terrell out of clemson who's a rookie
starting at the other corner they got
that ohio state corner too
yeah they like him yes yeah okay so
they re they really do so so they're
relying on
three corners that are young or younger
right
to uh to basically not save their season
but man that is that is some pressure
right there
in atlanta and peter peter speaking of
pressure last year
when they started one and seven going
into their bye week the worst time to be
one in seven when you've got two weeks
until your next game
that's usually when the coach is done
if he's going to be done dan quinn
wasn't fired then he wasn't fired at the
end of the season
how hot is that seat this year because
arthur blank
seems to be willing to stick it out even
though the results haven't been there
since the year they made it to the super
bowl
mike i mean i was sure he and gm thomas
dimitrov were
i was sure that they were gone last year
and
had they continued on that same path i
think they both would have been gone
but i give a lot of credit to arthur
blank here you know and at the end of
the year he basically said they're
coming back we're bringing everybody
back
you know the coordinators are back all
this uh
you know they made a change obviously a
defensive coordinator but
the you know they brought you know the
the
the guts of their team back the brain
trust is back
and i think arthur blank was saying look
i believe in you guys
but we gotta win and so there's a lot of
pressure i think on both of those guys
on dan quinn and thomas dimitrov but i
would just
i would also just say one other thing
about the falcons that i think
in my opinion is really really important
about
their season okay they're getting some
age at some positions right now i mean
alex mack is whatever he is 34.
julio jones is getting up there um
this is there this is not just about
okay you know or or the is the coach and
the
uh general manager on the hot seat this
is about
you know the alarm is starting to go off
here you know and they're gonna have to
do some major
you know sort of renovation to this
house
soon you know there's a lot of repairs
that are gonna be needed in the next
three or four years
so this is an urgent season
not just for the coach and general
manager but i think for their hopes
with this current team as it exists
right now
so peter what do you think they're going
to do because it's all saints and bucks
saints and bucks in that division
i see an opening and i think chris
agrees with me for the falcons to kind
of sneak up on everybody
if it can fall their way early and they
can develop some momentum
and win some games i think the biggest
thing in the nfc
this year and the thing that i heard out
there on the trail
is that people love having that extra
playoff spot
yeah because now what it's going to mean
essentially
if you look at the way this could fall
just
imagine if you're atlanta you get the
seventh seed and let's say
new orleans is the second seed i mean
honestly if you
look at the atlanta falcons over the
years against new orleans
even when they haven't been great
they've beaten them
they've played them great they know them
so well
and that is what i think would be kind
of a nightmare scenario in some ways for
the saints
but i think that everybody looks
at that seventh playoff uh slot
in both conferences as especially
in a crazy year like the one we have in
right now
everybody looks at this and they
basically say hey listen
nothing is out of the question you know
usually
eight and eight is you know you're
doomed but
one of these teams probably one of these
seven seeds has
got a good chance to be eight and eight
this year and so it all
matters it all depends how you're
playing
at the end of the season and i think
atlanta's got a shot
but again they're gonna have to i think
win some very high scoring games for
them to have a real chance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports